interesting now the biggest problem here
is that your answers were not specific
this is what i was talking about before
your answers might have been quite vague
what do we got here well
you have to think about in particular
and i haven't written this on here but
think about what they can get from you
already without the opal card
okay without the opal card existing
i think the department of transport
knows which stations are busy and which
stations are not does that make sense
in fact i think more or less any random
bystander
knows which stations are busy and which
ones are not
so if you said here okay predict
information that may result from the
process of data mining this
new database in part a and you said
they'll be able to identify peak times
and um the right kinds of you know the
most busy stations and people can open
up shops
people know all of that already has
nothing to do with opal okay
what are things that we don't know now
which we do know once you've got opal
um this is the main one okay consumer
travel patterns right
because they're attached to a card it's
not like
uh you know once i buy a ticket at one
station and then i buy a ticket at
another one
they're two completely different things
the department of transport doesn't know
that it's the same person who bought
both tickets right or three tickets or
four or five
but now every time i swipe on they know
ah it's the same number it's the same
one they go to this station and that
station and then you know five times a
day they're going right
so that's why i say it's attached to a
specific identity
rather than it's part of aggregated data
x okay um it's not just one big heap of
data which is like who knows who it is
right um it's actually attached to
specific people okay so it's a little
bit like the difference between when
google
when you go and do a google search right
versus when you do a google search when
you're signed in
if you're signed in they know who you
are so they can gather information about
you and what you search for
rather than just information about
random searches okay does that make
sense
yeah no yeah okay
um again this thing here the
relationship between the station of
origin
and the number of trips
it's okay i wouldn't be able to type
this much this quickly either
um because again if you didn't have opal
there'd be you'd know how many trips but
you don't know who's who right and you
don't know for instance that one person
is just going round and round
the train network like why would you do
that well i don't know but with opal you
can find out that
okay
okay this one again it has to do with
being connected to my identity
right so how would the department of
transport know
how many people are on their trains
right well without opal they can make a
good guess
because they've got the number of
tickets but you're going to do multiple
tickets per person
right so you've got to sort of scale
that number of trips down to okay how
many actual people have i got
right so when you've got opal that's one
person so you're not going to get double
ups of redundancy okay does that make
sense see how this is more specific
so i think you can read the rest and
you're going to get this document after
later
but that's that's the key right you've
got to think about what
information they wouldn't have without
the specific
scenario specific technology